bonsoir pour l'asl ailleurs merci
beaucoup d'être en direct sur rt france
bayemi netanyahu a jusqu'à minuit donc
un pour former un gouvernement encore
deux heures et 13 minutes précisément
faute de quoi elle devrait devenir chef
de l'opposition ce soir quelles sont les
options
personne ne comprend pas personne ne
sait ce qui va les options pour le
premier ministre sont de rendre le
mandat au président henri viii et c'est
sans doute ce qu'il va faire mais la
question est que va faire le président
avec son mandat at il le donne et
ailleurs la piste le chef de
l'opposition et le second candidat pour
devenir premier ministre
le transfert at il à nathalie bellec qui
est numéro trois dans la ligne de
succession
retournera-t-il le mandat au parlement
si le président oran le mandat au
parlement ils sont deux options
ils peuvent décider d'organiser une
cinquième à 5m scrutin où ils peuvent
demander un scrutin direct pour le
premier ministre du pays à ce stage
après on ne sait pas ce que le président
va décider de faire ce qui est clair
c'est que benyamin nétanyahou n'a pas
réussi à former un gouvernement
alors effectivement comme l'appui de ses
ailiers des partis juifs
ultra-orthodoxes n'est pas suffisant le
premier ministre a multiplié les
contacts ces dernières semaines dans
l'espoir d'atteindre ce seuil
vous le dites 1 pour l'instant en vain
comment expliquez-vous paula le refus de
tous les leaders politiques à ses
multiples tentatives et gestes tendu
politique c'est que chaque dirigeant
politique à son programme spécifique et
il y a tant de partis politiques qui
doivent se réunir si on peut espérer une
majorité de 61 sièges
par exemple des questions de religion et
d'état m'ont fait des repas divisait car
des partis anti netanyahu sont divergent
sur ce point par exemple le camp anti
natanyahou et fédérer sous une même
bannière à car ils considèrent que cela
fait trop longtemps
merci les difficultés comme vous le
savez un procès approche et pour eux ce
procès fait un tas israël il devait
s'agir d'ailleurs d'un très long procès
contre le premier ministre
il ya également parfois une forme de
vendetta personnelle contre le ministre
mais cela n'est pas suffisant de
fonceuse empêcher les divisions internes
des partis viennent par exemple ils
habitent les dirigeants de l'opposition
du conseil de rassembler et de partis
d'extrême droite et dessins gauche nous
mettrons jamais d'accord sur un grand
nombre de sujets à part leur détestation
de netanyahu alors si le premier
ministre échouer ce qui semble probable
en tout cas à cette heure ci sauf
surprise il faut dire qu'une page se
tourne pour l'état hébreu la première
fois depuis 12 ans
comment réagissent les israéliens c'est
pas rien
le ministre israélien benyamin
nétanyahou a eu la longévité la plus
longue depuis la création du pays devait
organiser des sondages en ce moment même
dans les rues d'israël sinon demandez
aux gens qui voudraient avoir comme
premier ministre environ 80 % des
israéliens soutiendrez encore netanyahu
et 20 perçant le dirigeant de
l'opposition et la bête notamment les
plus adroites payer la majorité du pays
il y aura beaucoup de tristesse et de
déception si benjamin netanyahu se
retire s'il est peu probable qu'ils
deviennent dirigeants de l'opposition
pour le moment car personne le pourrait
former une majorité parlementaire
j'ai parlé avec air l'api de dirigeants
de l'opposition et il ne peut obtenir qu
environ 50 des 61 sièges requis pour le
moment il est difficile de croire qu'il
pourrait y avoir bientôt un premier
ministre en israël
mais il est certain que la plupart des
israéliens seront déçus si le prochain
premier ministre n'est pas benyamin
nétanyahou pour la il deviendra alors
chef de l'opposition
quel type de chefs d'opposition
sera-t-il selon vous
c'est là que je ne pense pas qu'il
serait isolé dans l'opposition car il
aura le soutien des partis religieux de
tous les partis mig-23 il n'aura pas une
majorité des soutiens ce qui explique
effectivement qu'il va se retrouver dans
l'opposition plutôt qu au poste de
premier ministre mais comme je les dis
pour le moment personne d'autre ne peut
former de coalition donc il est
difficile de parler pour l'élément
d'opposition je souhaite également
souligner le fait que le système
politique israélien est complètement
fracture et nous en sommes à cinq
élections en l'espace de deux ans et
l'atmosphère en israël est une
atmosphère d'apathie les israéliens sont
las des élections ils ont assez de se
rendre aux urnes
le présent rivlin proposé hier la ville
de former un gouvernement
cela repousserait encore eu tout le
processus et ne ferait que renforcer la
frustration au sein de la population
israélienne
il faut également savoir que cela coûte
beaucoup d'argent à l'économie
israélienne
et cela renforce encore les frustrations
donc il y à beaucoup de tensions dans
les rues beaucoup d'appétit démocrate
est une autre question un susciter et
s'il y avait une autre élection quel
serait le taux de participation les
israéliens en majorité en ont assez de
ces élections incessantes qui ne
produisent aucun résultat réponse en
tout cas concernant benyamin nétanyahou
d'un peu plus de deux heures merci
beaucoup pour l'asl ailleurs joris
portée internationale d'avoir été avec
nous pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir